integration of my substitution is a big
topic okay
it's like a subheading under integration
but later on when we're looking at tree
growth industry is its own kind of
question okay so you really have to pay
attention play a good foundation now
okay now interaction my substitution in
many ways it's just like what we were
doing with the reverse chain rule and
we're looking at primitive functions all
over again
okay now being that it's a reverse chain
rule I just want to give you a head into
the right space let's think about how
chain knows when you differentiate
okay so let's consider I don't know
let's let's manufacture some function
like okay so we would use chain rule for
something like this okay
now you guys have gotten to the point of
it because you practiced it for so many
months but you can do this without
writing out the formal chain rule stuff
okay but later on when we're doing these
dissipation questions you're not gonna
be able to get away with us so easily
so if I'm gonna substitute something
into this to use chain rule I'd say let
you two now what would I choose yeah
just what's inside we've been calling
the inside function right x squared plus
3x okay now what that means is two
things number one this I could rewrite
as you to the form okay
and over here I can take this derivative
do you on DX right so I can
differentiate this inside function and
I'm gonna get 2x plus 3 okay
now the whole the chain of chain rule is
that if what I really want is to I on DX
okay then I'm gonna introduce the
derivative this dy do you and I'm gonna
multiply by this tribute I've already
got over here and my chain of D use will
cancel out okay now you guys know what
happens from here you can write down the
answer already
it's let's see 2x plus 3 times 3 you can
remove the board
you got it okay but it's these important
step over here that I want you to take
note on as we now have a look what
happens when we reverse the process okay
now I think it's exercise 20
that's the it's the Nexus aside off the
water 20:48 can someone read out the
first question - yep good okay and it
gives you a substitution on the end I
just want to look at it first and
everything and you can see why I would
say that this the substitution I'm about
to do is really reverse chain rule okay
because if you imagine what the
primitive was that landed here right
this 2x is coming from this process here
it was the inside derivative okay right
now how do I use this reverse changing
well there's helpfully said okay try
this substitution all right later on
you'll have to work it out on your own
but I think they say look x squared
minus one which so far looks just like
what we are doing here you pick this
inside function so just like before we
differentiate it right
why would do we differentiate here hmm
and the reason why is because yeah see
I'm gonna try and translate if you like
this whole question from X's into use
right that's what I'm gonna try and do
now I can translate that part into use
that's really easy because I've just
said that's what u is
but this part here that's a DX but I
want to turn it into a D you write the
only way I can change between different
types of D is by differentiating okay so
what's do you yes that's not so hard
okay but I don't want it in a fraction
form right I actually want the DX is
something like an x right so what I'm
going to do this next time here I'm
going to multiply both sides by DX okay
remember when we introduced integration
right DX is just that length right the
length of those infinitesimally small
rectangles so I can multiply divide by
it whatever I like yeah why do I want to
get to you right okay if I'm introducing
let u equal this
right I'm about to change parts of this
question so they're in terms of you
right but if some parts are in terms of
you I really need all the parts in terms
of you well that's the most
straightforward way so let me take this
okay and let's do the substitution right
this integral which is what I'm trying
to work out firstly is equal to this
okay all I've done is just swapped out
for you okay but this is the problem
right how do i integrate this with
respect to X it's not in terms of annex
right and that's why I'm gonna use this
okay so that to X and DX they're
together here they're separate here but
that's no problem right it's just a
product 2x DX they're together they're
going to become do you okay happy with
that so I don't to do here this is just
you know remember this is just a dummy
variable it might as well be next to the
4 DX doesn't matter so it's going to
become you to the 5 plus now that I
actually done my integration I can put
it back in terms of the X's which is
what I want
finished